c'est une ville éphémère déployés sur
près de 200 hectares chaque année en
juillet l'accueil toute la famille de
l'équitation française y compris les
lointains cousins
on y voit quasiment aucun cavalier
professionnel et encore moins deux
médaillés olympiques mais c'est
néanmoins la plus importante compétition
équestre en france c'est le premier
niveau de compétition que propose la
fédération pour l'ensemble de ces club
poney club centre équestre qui peuvent
proposer un projet pédagogique à
l'ensemble de leurs cavaliers dans une
trentaine de disciplines équestres
il ya environ six mille quatre cents
cavaliers différents pour 6100 équidés
différents ce qui nous fait sur la
totalité du mois de juillet un peu plus
de 15 mille cavaliers pour quinze mille
chevaux et poneys différents dont ils
vont fouler le sol du parc équestre au
mois de juillet 2018
et comme chaque jour 20 25 mille
personnes s'y croisent pour décrocher un
titre national ou accompagner un
cavalier qui est d'ailleurs le plus
souvent une cavalière
le lieu est aussi une vitrine
commerciale pour l'ensemble des
entreprises qui gravitent autour du
cheval
cette société créée il ya plus de 20 ans
dans l'oise a même déménagé en loir et
cher pour être chaque année au plus près
de l'open de france
c'est la plus grosse manifestation pour
nous de l'année qui le fait travailler
toute l'année on était en picardie avant
et on a déménagé pour être
justement sur notre site de production
juste à côté c'est la mecque de
l'équitation un lieu incontournable
jusqu'au 29 juillet incontournable peut
être aussi dans l'optique des jeux
olympiques de paris 2024 la ministre des
sports viendra en tout cas le visiter
lundi